hey guys my name is just it is februari
the fourth today and you're watching
games to eat halo 5 is getting a $25
microtransaction in the form of an arena
rec bundle in a post on Halo Waypoint
343 industries wrote that the bundle
comes with 14 rec packs all up to will
be released each week for seven weeks
the arena rack bundle will be available
from 316 a $25 warzone wreck bundle also
functions this way but it's been around
since Taylor class launched the content
is randomized but you'll get an
assortment of armors visors and weapon
skins buying the premium pack also
increases your shot at getting rare Rex
which include mythic and legendary items
on top of that if you pick up this new
pack you'll get the mark 5 alpha armor
set which is based off Master Chief's
armor in halo combat evolved halo 5s
existing line up of microtransaction
offerings range in price from two
dollars $200 Bethesda has revealed a new
trailer and release date for eid
software's long-awaited doom soon we'll
be out on me 13 for ps4 xbox one and pc
although a beta will be held sometime
before launch the bubble she revealed a
120 dollar doom collector's edition
which features a 12-inch statue of the
revenant as well as a copy of the game
in a middle case but there's also
announced that the demon multiplayer
pack will be a pre-order bonus it
consists of a demon armor set with three
skin variations 6p colors and three it'd
software patents for your gear you'll
also get six hack modules which are
consumable items for use in the game to
give you the edge in the arena finally
II and dice have released a new trailer
and announced a closed beta for Mirror's
Edge catalyst the beta will run on ps4
xbox one and on origin for PC if you're
keen you can sign up through the
official Mirror's Edge website for a
chance to be inside
in this announcement comes shortly after
a cryptic tweet was posted on the
mirrors edge account which read faith is
returning stay alert this week there's
no news yet on precisely when the beta
is going to take place or what it will
contain let me know down in the colors
of your more excited for Mirror's Edge
catalyst or zoom you can head to
gamespot we've got stroke on XCOM 2 and
how to get pearls 2016 for free that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today but you join the same time
tomorrow for the five biggest stories of
the entire week I will catch you soon